Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Korra it was viva la revolucion. As crazy
as things got there was still a lot of funny
moments thanks to Zuko, Asami and Bolin. And
in case you didn’t know already, Korra is
all digital meaning new episodes aren’t
airing on Television. You have to watch them
on the website or buy them in the google play
store or amazon. Really I’d just recommend
streaming them on the website, just because
they’re free.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I do weekly Korra videos. Be sure to
subscribe to get everything. There are 3 episodes
left.
For episode 10 I’m going to start with top
5 moments then I’ll do my review. Careful
for spoilers if you haven’t seen the episode
yet. I’ll wait just a sec...okay, everybody
ready? Let’s Go.
Number 5 - Bolin Makes Friends with The Red
Lotus
I love that he got 2 out 3 guesses right.
Based on the way Ming Yua looked away from
Ghazan when Bolin said there was an unspoken
attraction I think that was one of the correct
ones. Even though I think they wanted us to
think the moustache and sister ones were right.
When you listen to Bolin’s guesses again,
he’s really describing Team Korra. Raised
by an older sibling, that’s Bolin being
raised by Mako and unspoken attraction. That’s
kind of Makorra. The red lotus is a twisted
version of team korra. Or if you want to go
way back, a twisted version of team aang,
just because of the shaved head airbending
leader thing.
I also got the vibe that Ghazan was the Bolin
of their group. Like the one who gets to react
to everything. If you remember, he was the
one that got the funny reaction when Zaheer
and Pi Li started making out in their getaway
truck.
Bolin’s relentless positivity always makes
me feel better. It’s an animated show, so
his emotions are dialed up to 11 like he’s
super bipolar. But not spongebob levels of
bipolar so it’s not annoying.
That would actually be a cool subform of energy
bending. Emotion Bending. Then you could bend
all of the feels. Overly Friendly Bolin was
my favorite funny moment, but some alternates
were Zuko’s Dragon being lassoed to the
comically small palm tree and the other earthbender
in the cell next to mako and bolin.
Number 4 - Team Korrasami
How awesome are the two of them together this
season? If this were Scooby Doo she would
be like Velma in Daphne’s body and Korra
would be like Shaggy in Fred’s Body. That’s
not a dig at Korra in any way, it’s just
that I love how the dynamic changes from group
to group depending on who they pair up.
Korra is like a linebacker, fearless and ready
to go 24/7. Asami is the one who’s done
the homework. She knows the flaws in the Cabbage
Corp ships.
Which by the way was one of the best shade
throwing jokes on Korra this season. Let me
know if you caught it the first time around.
She’s basically throwing shade at cabbage
corp. Saying they totally suck.
The desert scenes were a whole other story.
They really reminded me of Last Airbender
when they went to the library. Plus the giant
sand fish was a nice reference to Frank Herbert’s
Dune. If you’ve never seen any of the versions
of the movie or read the books you should.
It’s some of the best science fiction you’ll
ever find.
The Sci Fi channel turned it into a miniseries
about 10 years ago, but the version most people
talk about is the David Lynch movie with Kyle
Maclachlan and Sting. I think that’s on
netflix.
Diving into the belly of the beast Number
3 - Korrasami escapes the Whale
I know I just referenced Dune, but you could
also compare this to Pinocchio escaping the
whale and the Millenium Falcon escaping the
space slug in Empire Strikes Back. I don’t
know which reference point Mike and Bryan
were going for but they all work.
I think it’s interesting how Korra didn’t
beat the crap out of everyone when the airship
crashed. She just apologized for tricking
the guard.
I think this is important foreshadowing for
how people are going to perceive her versus
Zaheer during the revolution in Ba Sing Se.
If she had taken them all down, she would
have been no better than Zaheer dominating
the Earth Queen.
This particular instance of Korra kindness
probably won’t make waves or anything, nobody
else was there to see her, so when she gets
to Ba Sing Se with Zuko and the rest of the
group, all Zaheer has to do is show everyone
how agressive she is. Making the red lotus
seem like liberators and anyone else by default
seem like opressors.
That’s the problem with being the Avatar,
you’d expect the White Lotus to be running
a PR campaign on your behalf, but right now
it seems like Korra has to sway public opinion
all by herself.
The only other Spin Guy they know that can
command peoples attention is Varrick. I feel
like he’s going to help them out in some
ridiculous way. Either with his magnets or
just by turning public opinion in Korra’s
favor using one of his devices.
On to the oh shit portions of the episode
Number 2 - Zaheer Airbends the oxegyn out
of the Queen’s Lungs
Just to be clear, this was not the sub-form
of airbending. He was still airbending air.
It’s just a very advanced form of airbending
because it requires precision. If he hadn’t
been so good at it he would have killed her.
What he did when he talked about darkness
was just making the Queen pass out from Oxygen
deprivation. When someone goes without air
in their lungs for more than a few minutes
oxygen stops circulating to your brain for
a short period and you pass out. Then reflexively,
your breathing muscles and your lungs start
up again. You can go for about 5 minutes without
air before things start to get really shitty
for you.
But the human body is designed to automatically
pump air if you faint or pass out. That’s
usually how people drown. They pass out, then
float underwater, then their body automatically
starts pumping in air but your underwater
so water gets in your lungs and bam, you drown.
That’s how most people die from drowning,
not from lack of air, but from breathing in
water.
and my Number 1 WTF moment - The Ba Sing Se
Revolution Begins
Technically it won’t begin until everyone
loses their shit and starts rioting in the
streets. Ghazan tore down one of the inner
walls. Probably the one that separated the
are between where Mako and Bolin’s family
lived and the wealthier inner city where Toph’s
family used to live.
That actually makes me wonder if Toph has
any cousins still living there. Her family
was almost as wealthy as the crown. There
would have had to have been a few cousins
floating around.
Zaheer is just lighting the match, once Ba
Sing Se riots I think his hope is that the
revolution will spread to all the other major
cities and everyone will do the work of tearing
down the governments for him.
Which brings up an interesting point. What
does he need Korra for if he can start the
revolution all by himself?
Remember how I said he’s probably going
to use her to sway public opinion more in
favor of revolution. One easy way to do that
would be for Korra to kill him in a very public
way. He’s already broadcast to everyone
in the city his intentions to liberate them.
So for them, he’s the good guy. If korra
were to kill him, that would make everyone
flip out in turbo mode.
That doesn’t mean that’s what he wants
her for, I just think it would be a very effective
way to accomplish his goal. To sacrifice himself.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was and what do you think he’s going to
use Korra for?
Even those this episode felt a lot smaller
than previous ones I gave it a solid A. The
animation was god damn beautiful and the character
beats were executed flawlessly. Bolin’s
funny moments show us that the red lotus are
real people, they’re not crazy villains
like Unalaq was. Bolin metalbending is going
to be his mount everest to climb in the next
3 episodes.
I think he’ll do it. As many downers there
are in Korra season to season, all of the
characters usually achieve their big triumph
by the end. Metalbending seems like Bolin’s
big challenge. And I think it’s more an
issue of him believing in himself. Part of
the reason I think he talks so much is because
he’s insecure, once he gets over that he’ll
probably find the inner peace to metal bend
the shit out of everything.
Zaheer feels like the big question mark right
now. I love how Henry Rollins has created
this ambiguous antagonist. Notice I didn’t
say villain. From his perspective, the villains
of the series are the politicians like the
earth queen. So he’s really just the counterbalance
to them.
The only way Korra will be able to stop things
from going crazy will be to neutralize zaheer,
all the citizens of every nation and the leadership.
No big deal right? That’s just like a million
different people to pacify.
Remember that Mike and Bryan said that her
solution this season won’t be based on her
bending ability. It’s not going to be a
physical fight.
That’s why I think Book 3 is so much more
interesting than Books 1 and 2. It’s more
of a philosophical journey than a slap fight.
Let me know where you think the season will
end? Last year things ended with spirit world
and the physical realm becoming closer than
ever. It feels like humanity is going to end
up becoming a lot closer to each other.
And another big question mark to consider
is what will be the macguffin to carry us
into book 4? Last year it was the joining
of the spirit and physical realms.
Here’s a crazy thought, what if all the
nations of the world joined together in a
democracy like Republic City? A republic is
the answer to feudalism. Even if Zaheer hates
all government.
Just something to think about. But time to
name a new winner in the weekly giveaway.
There are two again this week. Congratulations
to Michelle Fangirlando and Ian Bennett. You
guys both with giftcards. I’ll message you
on your channels for details.
Next week is episode 11. They’re just doing
the 1 episode per week now. They might end
up posting both the last two episodes together
but stay tuned I’ll post an update in next
week’s video if that’s the case.
I’m a little behind and I have a doctor
who video to make so instead of a Q&A that’s
probably what’s going to be next. Remember
I’m also doing a weekly doctor who giveaway,
so if you haven’t won anything from me before.
That’s just one more chance every week.
Right now click here for last week’s Korra
video and click here to learn all about the
Deadpool Movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!